these are some of the scenes in the
reckonist peninsula of Iceland after a
volcanic eruption began expelling lava
in the region this style of eruption
differs somewhat from the kind of
popular culture explosions that you
might
see here's why this eruption looks so
different and what threats it
poses Iceland is home to more than 130
volcanoes across more than 30 volcanic
systems and right now lava is erupting
out of the sareni volcanic system
located in the reckonist peninsula of
Southwest Iceland in a traditional
volcano the volcanic material funnels
through a central vent typically like in
those volcanoes that you ideate in
Hollywood where there is a mountain and
a conical Peak and the summit and the
everything like flows out of the summit
whether that's an ash boom that explodes
explosively into the sky or whether the
lava comes up and out of the center and
like leaks down the side of the mountain
here it's not like that instead in this
type of eruption known as a Fisher
eruption lava basically oozes from
cracks in the ground and the type of
lava typically involved in these two
kinds of eruptions also looks different
an explosive eruption is often due to
viscous sticky magma that doesn't flow
easily while a Fisher eruption pushes
out fluid and runny magma that spreads
across the landscape the big danger with
these is that these these lava flows can
spread out quite a long way and
obviously as we're seeing uh in Iceland
right now that poses a threat to both
the infrastructure in the region and
people's
lives the eruption from the speni
volcanic system occurred near grindvik
an Icelandic fishing town the
surrounding area is home to a major
airport one of the country's most
popular tourist attractions the Blue
Lagoon and a power plant that provides
hot water for the majority of the
peninsula eruptions in this part of
Iceland have been increasing steadily in
recent years after a very long dormant
period this is just an area of Iceland
that goes through these periodic eras of
on andof eruption activity and then
quesence so like around a millennia or
so the peninsula is quiet you don't see
volcanic activity and then it starts
up
and then that era of volcanic activity
lasts for centuries Iceland sits on top
of the aasian and North American
tectonic plates making it a hot bed of
seismic and volcanic activity when the
tectonic plates slip past one another
earthquakes occur and as the plates
spread apart magma can leak up to the
surface generating volcanic eruptions
the focus of sort of monitoring efforts
of volcanic systems is around trying to
identify as early as possible any
precursory signals that sort of come
before the onset of an eruption and in
instances like what we're seeing in
Iceland uh these eruptions are typically
heralded by the sort of really high
levels of seismic activity to try and
really tell us where there might be uh
an eruption and sort of where ongoing
intrusions are are going it remains to
be seen how the lava erupting from the
sparten volcanic system will impact
residents in the surrounding area but
the risk of volcanic activity also comes
with benefits for the Icelandic
Community every expert from Iceland who
I spoke with was very proud of the fact
that the country uses their volcanoes in
a constructive way they harness
geothermal energy from them to generate
electricity and heat their water and
Heat their homes and they don't need to
buy oil to do those things because
they're exploiting their Volcan
basically but of course the trade-off
there is in order to exploit them best
you have to be close to them and if
you're close to them eventually an
eruption will threaten homes threaten
towns and cities and with risks come
[Music]
benefits